yeah I feel like you've kind of like
done a really good job of like
I guess being in the right circles
having the right people co-sign you yeah
yeah and I think that's really important
too you know like uh the whole [__] went
out I was like Monumental for me to be
able to have like him do my first solo
you know EP and then through there
that's how like you know me and Gunn and
Conway met you know what I'm saying like
the first tour I ever went on was uh it
was just me and Conway uh gun and Benny
it was just us four
yeah what's so a side track what's up
with the Griselda debut so you know it's
guns are busy dude I'm a busy dude we
want to make sure that it's done right
we want to be in the lab at the same
time you know uh
I have you know
producers that I work closely with he
has the producers that he works closely
with and
we're just gonna come put it together
and uh it's got to be a pot of Gumbo but
you guys got to kind of be actively
working on it for sure because like you
know you need to be in there with
conductor and all that conductor you
know what I'm saying and Derringer well
me and Derringer got an EP done but we
we keep like
changing it up but um
yeah and monk you know what I'm saying
but the thing is with that it's like
it's just timing man everybody's busy
and moving around but it's gonna come I
want my debut solo to come out on
Griselda so
it's crazy you say that and you have so
much music yeah because I won't even be
able to put out my solo album this year
I got me and rock Marcy album The me
Kamai and Harry Fraud and then I got a
funk album with um with uh Dame Funk and
um and then I got another album with
cocaine the singer and those are yeah me
and cocaine got like a whole like kind
of like a funk group we doing called
Billy Ocean where
um I've taken some of the cats that
produce for like selection like I am
nobody yeah and then um Jake won and
traffic leaving Cali you know what I'm
saying and then uh me and Sean and you
know me and Coca got some cold [__] so
it's a lot of it's tough because you
know like us in the Indie like I don't
like saying underground you know what
I'm saying I like to remove that word
but I said underground is kind of not a
thing anymore no it used to be a thing
but I feel like
there's so much there's just some genres
of this [__] there's the independent I
mean yeah I feel like the underground
[__] is out the door I feel like it
because it's like would you call what
Larry and Alchemists are doing
underground I wouldn't I was that's a
major roll-up you know what I'm saying
like and it's being pushed um because
back in the day you would think of like
guys like Dilated Peoples it's
underground yes but it wouldn't even
really be underground because they were
on capital or like yeah yeah yeah even
like the raucous record [__] or but the
real underground [__] out of La was like
project blow project blow free stuff
yeah bus driver all those and and I got
a lot of history with those cats when I
was like 13 you know uh I was running
around like with um with uh with cve and
and and La cool rifle man and soaking up
game that type of music actually opened
my whole [__] up because I really only
like was listening to gangster rap and
like East Coast [__] at the time and
then I was like oh it's some [__] coming
out of L.A that's like different you
know what I mean so uh how old are you
oh we gonna do that well I'm trying to
figure out because I'm an 80s baby you
know what I'm saying I'm born in 87 but
I was my best friend's brothers and
Dilated Peoples oh yeah so when I was
like who's your best friend's brother
Rocca oh [__] yeah you know Evans my boy
yeah that was my boy too yeah that's
right I've known evidence I was 13.
really yeah damn so I like
I remember seeing them
uh on the platform tour and then when
they dropped expansion team we came out
here when I was like 14 and went to the
record release party and [__] fat
beats and they had to show Jurassic five
at some [__] and then then when they had
the marathon drop they were they opened
up for Kanye a House of Blues yeah so I
was around all that [__] bro yeah yeah
yeah that [__] was dope man that whole
like um like that's why even like while
we talking about this like I like to do
[__] and bring like for me I like to
work with people that I grew up on like
so I'm like I did a song with Tash and
we just put out a video shout out to the
licks man shout outs to the licks rap
life that's one of my favorite albums
man that was the [__] that him and him
and uh rake one had that video that was
the [__] but you know like for me like
you know Tad Tash I invited Tash and he
Swift to my house and then I was like
let's shoot this video I bought like a
whole in Compton I bought this whole
[__] like Warehouse full of like
vintage denims and like I got dead stock
for days like FUBU averex Pelle Pelle
you got traffic denim jackets denim
shirts everything we about to launch um
about to launch a store with um
this uh reworks company called Frankie
Collective so that's going to be coming
in the spring you know what I'm saying
when I was like Friday 15 we'd get them
for Burlington but they'd be like
[__] 4X yeah they'd be 4X yeah you
see they're coming back though
they all like relaunching their [__] and
like you know I always been into
um fashion like people don't know this
but I'm like you know the you know kind
of the
I don't know what my title is I would
say but you know maybe the head of
marketing over at Pro Club you know what
I mean I took that and saw an
opportunity to be like this is a dope
ass this is a staple it's a staple we
grew up on it in the hood everybody grew
up on it in LA and like I wanted to see
it just you know still keep its roots in
the swap meets and liquor stores but
start doing collaborations so when I
came on board we did the collaboration
with YG at complexcon started doing the
um three packs with FTP we did the
pop-up for Shoreline at um
didn't cookies just do a Pro Club yeah
well we did that yep and and then we had
you know burner was rocking that Pro
Club on the Forbes which was tight you
know what I'm saying so you know uh the
fashion [__] is always I feel like being
a part of um you know music every every
rapper had when they was popping every
rapper had a brand if it was Nas it was
Esco of course I I always thought Johnny
Blaze was Method Man because he's Johnny
Blaze yeah yeah was I just remember
seeing the [__] in the source I never
got any of it yeah yeah yeah so they had
a gang of that [__] so I just grabbed
all that [__] so we'll see what it do
with that I'm also gonna launch my own
line this year but you know uh back to
the tax story uh I was like yo let's
shoot a commercial for my uh for my uh
all the Vintage pieces and jump jump on
this old [__] and we shot a video but I
just like to work with cats that you
know I grew up listening to so when I
was able to meet Cube and you know
corrupt and and Bun and all these cats
it's like a blessing to me man because
you know that's what inspired me
um to do what I do so for me it's like
the 13 year old me is like living your
dreams I'm living my dream yeah right
you know